最初に一つお願いがあります
今回2回ほどまあささやかなジョークを言いますのであの皆さんあの笑ってください
お願いしますご協力をお願いします
さて人工知能という言葉をみなさんよく最近聞くと思います
こんにちはペッパーです
彼もまた人工知能が搭載されています
あるいは
超常的な出来事として
ディープマインド社が開発したあるファーゴという ai が
プロの囲碁の棋士を破り世界最強の気性も凌駕する状態になっています
もう今や囲碁の世界で神様とまで呼べるような囲碁の会愛が登場しています
このような
以後の分野での画期的なプログラムを登場のように非常に今
人工知能が進化しているわけですけれどもこのような進化を目の当たりにして不安に
思っている方もおられると思います
巧妙な
車椅子の宇宙物理学者のスティーブンホーキング博士は
人工知能は人類に最悪の結果
あるいは最良の結果をもたらすだろうと
入っています
あるいはて須田 ceo の
イオマスク氏は
ai 開発は
悪魔を召喚する商業だと
強い調子で警鐘をならしております
私は今日日本の宇宙物理学者の一人として
決してホーキング博士に対抗するつもりはありませんがちょっと違うことを言いたいと
思います
それは
ai はほかなるこの日本という国では
救世主あるいは天使になりうるような存在だと
皆さんを持っていただくとが容易ではないでしょうかとそういうことを今日お伝えし
たいと
今人工知能がこれほど話題になっているのはディープラーニングという技術が花開いた
からです
現在コンピュータの能力が非常に進化し
またビッグデータの時代が到来しそしてこの
ディープラーニングという技術が花開いたことによって
非常に大きな進化を ai が解けました
arche
大きな壁を越えたわけです
そして壁の向こう側には
非常に新しい今まで誰も見たことなかったような世界が確実に広がっています
壁の外に
人を喰らう巨神ベルそのようなことを心配しないで
積極的に新しい世界でていきましょうとそういうふうに僕は考えています
さてこの deep learning ですが
人間の頭脳のまあ中の機能である
まあでニューロンのネットワーク
それを模擬した
ものです
現在どういうことが可能かといいますと例えばこのような
画像
ニューラルネットワークコンピュータージョンの由良ネットワーク入力すると自動的に
キャプションをつけることができます
例えばこのようにこのような画像からまあある程度正しいキャプションをつけることが
できるわけですけれどもこれは
今の ai は
画像を
理解し始めているということを意味しています
もう少し別な例としては例えばこんな画像があったとします
この画像を例えば誰でもコンピュータを使えば
井戸愛を変えることは簡単ですこれはまあ誰でもできるんです
例えばこのように
少し
色合いを変え
そういうことができるわけですけれども今
このディープラーニングという新しい技術を使うと全く異なった画像の変換が可能です
ま例えば
このような形で
左の絵からわずか1分程度で右のようなよー
ai が描いてくれます
これよく見ると色々気づくわけですけれどもま例えば
フサフサっとした髪の毛やまあフサフサっとした
羽根が
金属のような
ものに変えられています
これはですね ai が
ふさふさ at した神系とか言う
アルシュ曖昧なことをちゃんと認識できているということです
ここが決定的にもで撮っちゃいます
つまりですねまあ今までのまた画像変換のプログラムというのは人間があらかじめ
どのように処理をするかを与えていてこれはある種言語で記述したり
数式を使って記述たりする訳ですけどそういう人間が決まったルールを与えて処理する
のがまあ今までの画像変換であったわけですがいい
はの ai ができることはそうではなくて
ai が自分で学習した結果を基に抽象的な概念を身につけていてそれによってフサフ
サっとした髪の毛というものを
認識できるわけです
そこが山でとか画期的に違うわけです
今回大学生のみなさんがほとんどですのでその大学生のみなさんにとって
まあ監視なりそうなでちょっとことを一つ紹介したいと思います
例えばですね今
就活の場面
人材採用の場面に ai がまさに入り込み始めています
例えばリクルート社は
ai に過去の膨大なエントリーシートと人事担当者の評価データを学習させて
エントリーシートの評価書類選考にこの ai を
使い始めていますん
このような動きは実際に他の企業にもまさに
まぁ今回の就活や
その次の就活から本格的に使われ始めると予想されています
このようにリクルート社の場合ははっきりとこういうことを言ってるからいいんです
けども
懸念されることとしては
ai を使って書類選考していることを企業が思っていた際可能性もあります
あるいはまた
懸念としては
神乳担当者がどのように ai が判定しているか判断しているかが分からない可能性
あるてことですよ
これはですね先ほどの画像の変換の例のように
抽象的な
知識をもとに判断できますので
これは言語化されていないので人事担当者にその判断基準が分からないわけですよ
もう一つ重大な問題としては
ai が誰も気づかないうちにいつのまにか
過去のデータの学習から偏見を組み込んでしまっている可能性があります
例えばですね
過去の膨大なデータから
メガネをかけている人が
昼食後まあ入社後パフォーマンスが高いと
なんかそういうデータもし学習すしてたとしたら何が起こるかというと
あるときみんな消すわけですねうちの会社はみんな名金かけてないか
こういうことが起こるわけですその時になってようやく気付くわけです
これは ai が眼鏡を重視してるぞ
これ冗談じゃそういうことが本当に遅れてしまうなんですね
その時になってまぁ変えればいいかもしれないんですけどもこのように
偏見を ai が持つかもしれないアルゴリズの偏見と言いますかこういう問題もあり
ます
このように新しい問題が色々起こり得るんですけどもまぁ今日のポイントはそういう
まあことを頭に置きつつもむしろわれわれの未来を切り開く手段として考えていこうで
はないかと
特にそれは日本でこそそう考えるべきだということです
それはですね
日本では
人類の歴史経験したことないような超高齢化社会が確実に訪れます
果たして日本の社会は持続可能なんだろうかそういう懸念があるわけです
そういった懸念を考える上でこの ai の進歩が
救世主になるかもしれません例えば現在でも
画像認識が非常に発達しているので
医療の現場でもまさに使われ始めています画像診断
あるいはですねこの先数年先には
ai 搭載したロボットが
実現します
これは人間のように動けるロボットということで
そうなるとですね例えば介護の分野あるいは
家事全般
そういったところにも ai で動くロボットが活用される
十分にそれがあり得る状況に
いきましたイメージするならばスターウォーズの
銀色のやつとあとはまあもうちょっと箱型のやつですねあの黄色の方が足りないです
はっきり言っ
しかし四角い箱型の方あっちと
組み合わされば非常に
役立つ頼りになるロボットが実現するわけです
そのようなことが実際におります
どのくらいこれが社会的にパクトあるかははっきり言って想像できないわけです今では
非常に大きな社会インパクトを持っていくと私は考えていますけどもまぁこれは今後
我々
どのよう
にこの a 合う社会に組み込んでいくかということに関わってきます
今回私が言いたかったことはこの日本の超高齢化社会を乗り切るために
明るい日本の未来を創るために ai をみなさん
考えていませんかということです
最後は政府のまあ所の的になってしまいますけれども日本の政府実はそういったことを
言っていますそれはですね
ソサエティ5.0という社会を日本が目指すべきだと政府が言っている
これはですね人工知能社会の基盤的な技術で組み込んで
日本人の誰もが
快適で
活力に満ちた質の高い生活を送れるような社会にして江町スマート社会にしとくこう
いった
外んです
人工知能社会に久美子飛び組み込むことによってこういうことが可能になると私は思っ
ていて皆さんと一緒に明るい未来の舞がいていければなと
特に今回は若い大学生のみなさんが思うですので皆さんまさに
これからを担う世代ですんでぜひともそういった目で
新しい技術に向き合ってもらえば
きゃっていただければいいなと思う
[拍手]